hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play cry of fear
the Scrolls of shy moon alright this is
probably I think this is the absolute
last custom campaign as far as this
update goes so after this one there may
not be a more for a while until I think
I think crime viewers gearing up for a
steam release I'm not sure but hopefully
after that more people will be
interested in making more of these
awesome custom campaigns so let's get
into it
ma'am madam may be young bring it on
what do you got for me Oh oh wow okay
enough with the screaming I get it looks
like our way in was caved good okay so
we're exploring some weird temple hey
where did everybody go well isn't this
interesting
huh there's definitely a very different
setting from what I'm used to I like it
a lot let's go in let's not go in
oh oh I like it already
oh my god what happened here I should
pick up that blade just in case what
what the hell you're not gonna get up on
me are you you're a good cop of it okay
so something happened back this way what
happened oh this this area over here
opened up for is that where I came in
from oh god I hate this place I hate
this place Breann it's stuck it I think
I don't want to go in there either
holy crap oh oh this custom campaign
started off with a bang
oh look I sworn that was gonna collapse
with me on it oh my god oh you're not
gonna get up are you buddy got some
holes in your heads how about some more
I'll take that a gun no no no no none
but it's empty good Paul man I do not
like this place I heard something like a
growl I feel like I'm being watched
yeah about that
I've never seen that before oh I see you
in there we're gonna do about that
okay get out get out here hey wait ah
stop it's gonna Saba tonight I don't
have a gun to do suicidal influence on
me you back off Jesus rise what is wrong
with this game I need to reload
oh no I'm already loaded up Ha Na da how
are you getting out air look how the
hell did you get me out here
Oh screw you screw you
Oh screw this whole place there's no
place oh this whole place to go home to
[ __ ] are you
whoa you don't know anything okay yeah
cool what the [ __ ] is that
a statue strange there's a glow to it
what if I what smack it smack it hang on
that's not right Aion give me my knife
huh what if I what what if I would shoot
it
Oh what that's my save point ha ah man
you are one cool tape recorder okay Oh
God did someone got dragged here use
better English bread well apparently
it's not gonna be me
oh man I feel like the guy who made this
like took all the worst sounds from cry
fear like were step-in scariest send
Sophie thank god she's alive
you
I still hear it
why how's this a door opening I don't
like this place Oh Oh Oh what was that
why'd that suddenly stop or that
suddenly go and then why did suddenly
stop why why why why what what what why
why why why oh why why why why why why
why what why why why why why why why why
why [ __ ] on
Oh what the hell hi don't push me off of
my person my [ __ ] hurt I can't
[ __ ] move
it's pushing me off it's [ __ ] pushing
me off I'm being pushed around I don't
know why
oh man what the hell what the hell is
that oh now I can go through good good
good good how you [ __ ] off you [ __ ]
right off what the hell was that those
were my friends what the hell is going
on here those weren't your friends brah
ray Brewer let's we're your friends
oh look giant gold statue giant gold
savepoints I should take all this gold
[ __ ] night it looks valuable so get
something out of this whole ordeal uh
what is this lever oh god you are the
same
I won't you say what does that do what
that do what that do I think I can move
this block really holy crap you is
strong whoa what the ho dude your eye I
might have just Bork the game ho what
does hey what the hell ah do you got to
be kidding me
you got to be kidding me this is how my
adventure ends I managed to whoa what
the hell the physics are so wonky I
don't even what I know what huh how'd it
how the and now it's stuck it was stuck
in the ceiling it got out of there
what uh-oh what done hey dude seriously
ah no I'm suck [ __ ] what the hell oh you
gotta be kidding me what Duff how do you
put implement that and not say that it's
a giant cluster [ __ ] well looks like I'm
stuck what oh come on this was going to
be the best custom story ever Hollis I
was the best and this happens
how did I get stuck how did you get
stuck I think I can move the block Yeah
right Jesus
you kidding me [ __ ] all right geez oh
that's [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] because I'm so frickin
far away for uh whatever and the game
crashed of you have got to be kidding me
I was so immersed I was so into it I was
so there I was so terrified and now the
game has crashed that might have
corrupted my whole save that is so
disappointing that is so unbelievably
disappointing I am so sad that that
happened I hope I hope my save isn't
corrupted or something I'm gonna go back
in here alright starting recording in
hang on hang on hang on starting
recording three two one okay um no hang
on load game the research room okay I'm
in it I'm in it I'm in it I'm in it I'm
in it I'm in it I'm in it okay so I go
from here do I already have the gun
I have gun I've done
okay so if he's not alive and I go out
here ah that's so broke my concentration
I was oh it was like it was like the
most amazing custom campaign I've ever
seen in my life and then it just goes to
[ __ ] ah that is such a giant
disappointment I'm so sad that that
happened because now
I'm like totally broken
hi so unfortunate that's so unfortunate
I'm so sorry guys if that happened I
don't know why if it was something that
I did that I could have prevented ah
[ __ ] I just wasted a whole clip ammo
well away whatever there we go okay so
I'm not that far off man ah this ah
golly
okay let's try this again
I still don't know how I'm gonna get
that block to where it needs to be
because I mean holy hell this block
seems a little movable it doesn't seem
any movable at all whoa what uh-oh don't
tell me you're gonna do the wonky
physics don't do the wonky physics on me
you're doing the wonky physics okay
alright whatever you know I'm just gonna
try to be very gentle about this you
know I know the half oh all right hold
on I know the half-life a physics system
was a little wonky but wow this is like
the worst implementation to ever okay
whoa whoa whoa hold up hold up hold up
hold up hold up okay now you go wait a
little more oh closed okay so alright so
you're there does that mean I can get up
here and then oh hello more ammo okay so
let's concentrate back on getting back
into it
[ __ ] come on come on come on
crouch job ah there we go there we go
well I can't get up there what the hell
I can't get up there and let me get it
closer there we go right there ought to
do it now if I go again with the awesome
epic Crouch jump and then oh god there's
no way ah [ __ ] how the hell am I gonna
get up there what am I gonna do here
this [ __ ] this bowl is BS
do I need that other block somehow
that's now embedded in the ceiling oh my
goodness
okay this block seems slightly taller so
ow
fire hurt fire hurt me fire stop hurting
me okay so very subtly whoa whoa what da
hell man
Jesus ease up ease up on your wild
physics bro this is insane okay it's
like this this - it's like completely
breaking the immersion I'm Sam I'm just
I'm just kind of disappointed I'm just
kind of disappointed this is kind of
unfortunate it was going so uh
ah hold up wha what the hell stop it I'm
like oh don't be stuck not the UH okay
calm your tits box GJ's us okay
just hold there hold there Jesus okay
there we go finally jeez all right let
me save alright I mean what da hell man
game maker you were doing so good then
that okay let's see what else you got in
Cornbury
what was that I saw like Simon but he
had like a cape on whoa hello puzzle
jumping puzzle jumping oh oh oh I'm bad
at this huh no save either oh wait no I
just saved Oh God ah oh it's not gonna
go well it's not gonna go well it's not
gonna go all ah uh-huh
needle ate my run juice get up oh that's
a Crouch jump that's a run Crouch jump I
go god I hate this oh I shall not
survive
okay oh man I'm just frankly I'm just
disappointed I'm just disappointed this
was gonna be I was gonna I was already
prepared delicious is my favorite custom
campaign and then ah okay come on okay
let my Oh hold up let my run juice climb
back up I also need to free up my mouse
cuz I was charged again the USB was
plugged in cameras tricks okay so
alright alright here we go
oh it's it's having a sprint and then
crouch jump it's very yeah ah come on
ah mother of [ __ ] you gotta be kidding
me
this is fun no answers no answers this
is not fun
I know that there are like whole Maps
dedicated to half-life case you didn't
know what happened there is when you
DoubleTap a direction you'll leap
backwards or you'll leap in that
direction you double tap which is just
fantastic for puzzles like this because
you can when I'm see I'm steadily
adjusting I've done very subtly adjust
okay maybe I don't need sprint for any
of these maybe not okay
didn't need sprint on that one up maybe
just crouch jumping a let me go through
it ah yeah so far so good yeah oh yeah
okay so maybe that was my fault it sure
looked like I would need sprint there
but whatever whatever
King Tut Simon
hahaha it was King Tut Simon Simon the
Pharaoh our Dada book oh well piss I
fell in the hole water water everywhere
I weren't where am i where am I give me
out of the water
oh come on chapter 2 hat oh boy
now it's just turning into a puzzle
platformer man
I'm so into it I'm so into it and then
then just nothing nothing it's I don't
know I don't even know anymore
the door is jammed the tour is jammed
the door that is loud this is fun this
is so fun or it won't puzzle hmm oh
hello you is shiny okay so maybe I gotta
hop on the scare Rabb's or system's
gonna be trial and error
oh how wonderful Oh God ah there we go
how wonderful
why not why not why not I'm just I'm so
sad right now I'm I'm about as sad as
I've ever been in my life
playing a game that I was enjoying
thoroughly and having it all ripped away
from you just take it just take it away
I just ripped apart ripped right out of
your soul and nothing screams good game
mechanics like trial and error all right
so maybe maybe there's something logical
about this other than high explosives in
an ancient Egyptian tomb do I see any
clues there anything that would present
a good case for me to cross no all right
then good there holes in each of these
it was that okay maybe I'm supposed to
see something through the holes or not
I don't know oh it's fire it's fire
that's killing me
fire is killing me wonderful that makes
it so much better okay
I'm just kind of sad right now I'm kind
of sad this was like seriously honestly
this was probably one of the scariest
custom campaigns I was ever playing
through it was in an original location
it was going so well than this okay I
have no idea what I'm supposed to do
here I can't tell I can't tell a
solution
I really can't and that's really
unfortunate hey honey I can't even see
in the water here so diving down
probably wouldn't get me anything I
can't
ah man all right you know what I've been
playing this while I'm just kind of I
kind of broke out about nuts I'm not
into it enough so I don't know I got a
save here if you guys want me to pick it
up I will if you got some tips er how to
get through that next part maybe it's
obvious maybe I'm just not seeing it
because I've done that in do it anymore
but I mean it kind of just is
disappointing me at this point I'm sorry
about that I really wish I was more into
it but the whole physics breaking thing
and then this puzzle-platformer jumping
and then turning into a trial and error
runtime
I'm not into it so let me know if you
want to see the ending I will play the
ending if you all want me to see
playthrough the ending I mean I'll do
what you guys want to do but so far
thank you so much for watching hope you
enjoyed it at least the beginning part
so thank you again as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
hey you well f you buddy door